wow i mean i'm surprised i had that much
to say but damn
no this one hit me a lot this one hit me
a lot
what's going on reject nation so this
morning i put out a
tweet declaring who my favorite batman
is out of the live action
and then a lot of people proceeded to
tell me that about this uh
snyder cut batman and superman trailer
that i was not aware about so
thank you guys for always keeping me up
to date can't tell you how much superman
content
i have consumed in the past couple weeks
just recently watched man of steel again
watched batman v superman ultimate
edition and upon watching it on sunday i
really think i want to change my rank
and i'm pretty sure that ultimate cut
is is above man of steel for me now uh
it is
so good i just got more things from it i
talked a little bit about it
after we're done you know checking this
out and play some injustice 2 as i was
letting a video export for 45 minutes
you know for superman and lois hopefully
you guys can go check that out superman
this is another one
we just put up episode 2 today so
there's a lot of dc content in my noggin
right now
let's see what everyone was all hyped
about in this video so that there's hype
that means there's some new stuff to
listen to
or see
[Music]
is that dark side yeah it sounds like
you there's something that
can help you it's time
it's worse than manhattan
[Music]
make this right
[Music]
ah look at that war machine at the
beginning there oh we gotta watch that
again we gotta watch that again
that's definitely that's gotta be that's
a reporter
you fulfilled your promise yes
and the music is so epic yeah man these
strings
now you have to unite us
unite us you got cyborg and flash fist
bump in there
so great
oh we gotta hear we gotta hear harry
lennox there it's fascinating watching
like man of steel and batman v
superman and being aware that like yes
he for sure will be martian man hunter
will be revealed and that he's kind of
like hiding in the shadows you know i
have a stake in this world and it's time
i start fighting for it and we've all
been wanting martian manhunter
on a very personal note uh especially
for me
because years ago when i first went on
movie fights
and then i did such a terrible job that
i wasn't invited back for a couple of
years before i learned how to properly
play the game and argue on that screen
chunky show they were asked like who
should join justice league and i opted
for martian manhunter i
sucked at arguing it but i've always
wanted martian manhunter to be here so
i'm so
excited i don't know who like there's
some like reports in the past of
explaining more of what lex's whole
ordeal is in this movie
and uh i'm i'm not exactly sure who he's
talking to i want to say let me know
down below
if you do know but i also like i'm kind
of glad i forgot
yeah so that way i could just let some
things be a surprise because already so
much
has been revealed about this movie over
the years
um down now it's about watching it all
play out watching the bvs ultimate cut
i'm like you know
freaking jesse eisenberg gets clowned on
a lot but i love him in that movie
i really do i think he's awesome in that
movie well in the ultimate
cut his character breathes better and it
makes a bit more sense i don't know
there's something about that theatrical
cut that i think just enhances the sort
of like what is happening here quality
of that and i hope that maybe in this
movie at least to some extent he gets a
little bit of a redemption too
justice for lex i mean he's gonna be an
actual character in here and not
just the post-credits scene you know
like we've seen the war machine images
of the tank
like watching it in the slow motion
reveal is so
damn beautiful god it looks straight out
of the graphic novel
it reminded me of what i enjoy and look
forward to about these zack snyder
movies most in a way because yeah it is
like a living breathing comic book panel
and
it has a knack for doing like regardless
of what you think of the tone or what
ideas he wants to play with like there
is never a shortage of just exquisite
and beloved comic book-esque shots yeah
and i like that the trailer is bringing
it back to the heart of batman
and superman because i'm telling you
guys if you haven't seen the ultimate
cut you've got to watch the ultimate cut
because
everything just makes so much more sense
and it's just such a much better movie
than the theatrical one
you know and having this line in here
that of batman
talking about how he spent so much time
trying to divide us now it's about
bringing everyone together
unite the league that to me is the
symbolism
of what this has all been building up to
what this trilogy
is all about in a lot of ways this
really is the superman arc
you have man of steel this alien that
comes here
and then after the end of that it opens
the door for all these other things
and then you got lex luthor then the
creation of doomsday superman's death
awakening the mother boxes bringing
steppenwolf
and darkseid coming here you guys know
how it goes but then also with batman
where batman is at at that point in the
movie obviously he's
he's just a guy who's constantly walking
around with pain in his eyes
everywhere he goes that being a version
of batman that doesn't mind killing
that really doesn't bother me in that
movie this line hits home especially
hard for me this week
because i've clowned so much on that
martha moment i did a whole video
years ago about how ridiculous that is
like the whole video was dedicated to
that
and then upon watching it this sunday it
actually really
hit me how much it works following that
moment i actually got
teary-eyed because that whole movie
batman
is all about how this guy is an
alien and he doesn't even seem like he
trusts meta humans you know
just feels like push to the edge here
he's getting pushed and pushed and
pushed
until he finally is like i gotta kill
him i gotta steal the kryptonite i gotta
take him out
batman is just this super traumatized
character who only views carl
clark he doesn't even know him as clark
kent he just views superman
as this terrorist as this alien this
this threat to humanity so he's
literally about to
murder him with the kryptonite spirit
that whole thing with him
with him saying save martha clark would
say save martha because he's not gonna
say save my mom batman's not gonna know
who that is
and i believe in that moment he thought
he was actually gonna die because that's
also his first time dealing
with someone using kryptonite on him as
a weapon
like it's not a man of steel where
anyone's doing that he's in the
kryptonian ship at one point so he
starts losing
uh his power and strength but this is
the first time he's dealing with an
enemy who's
usually who's actually using kryptonite
on him and now he's becoming very weak
he thinks he's gonna die
so i think there's so much happening in
that scene when he says save martha
you got batman who's like feeling
triggered obviously by his
trauma but i also was like wait a minute
he's viewing this guy as an alien
and then when he finds out martha is his
mom that's working on so many different
complex layers
yes with batman's mom being named martha
and the loss of her but also
this guy is no longer an alien in his
eyes what alien would have a mummy
i think so much starts happening starts
clicking with batman in that moment of
this guy is actually like a human well
yeah
and they say in your final moments like
it reveals who you really are and by
that logic then it's like
what is clark's mind go to please just
save my mom that's all i want
yes and so there's that's what i mean
that identity
just starts to form and honestly by the
time superman is like i gotta go save my
mom and then batman stops him and says
i'll save martha like he interrupts like
of course superman
i remember when i saw the theatrical
come like superman just dude he could do
it faster
batman going in there but in that moment
that means so much to batman to be able
to do that he wasn't able to save
his mom he wasn't able to save his
martha and now
he's able to i can't believe i'm [ __ ]
defending this
so now he's so he's able to go in there
it brought me to tears in that moment
because he's like i wasn't able to save
my mom
i wasn't able to say my martha but i'll
save this martha i'll save her
it's like trying to make up for that and
like that that right there is
the trajectory of batman instead of
being like
[ __ ] i'm going to terrorize the
criminals to being a hero again like
yeah
really being a hero i'm going to
save someone now you know since hearing
you even talk about this now it makes
that shot in this little ad
of batman like kind of helping superman
up like them taking each other by the
hand and them you know standing together
yes more meaningful and more exciting to
see that play out in the actual
movie ahead because yes they gotta fight
doomsday together
uh but they didn't really get to have
this moment of
kinship yeah you know mutual recognition
and you're gonna get that and batman's
whole philosophy on everything is
changing as opposed to him being against
metahumans against aliens and now here
he is uniting everyone and realizing
these are the people we need
to be the heroes this is full circle
this is beautiful to me
yeah so yeah man
i could go on and on about that ultimate
cup but guys yeah martian manhunter
i got a whole lot to say it's time for a
haters why we love
bvs ultimate edition podcast
wow i mean i'm surprised i had that much
to say but damn no
this one hit me a lot this one hit me a
lot ah that line was powerful
guys leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button last but not least
david gandy john shouting out
hi shout outs i just wanna make you feel
excited david and what's more exciting
than those wacky waving inflatable arm
flailing youtube men i just want to
bring some motion
and some rhythm to your day your musical
guy
and also i mean you've been through the
ringer lately and i'm just glad that
you're persevering and you're hanging in
every time i get a message from you
i'm always kind of astonished at how
you're able to remain so sort of
positive and well adjusted despite some
of the challenges that you face and i'm
like the shitty life you had
despite how terrible no but seriously
and i'm glad that you have people around
you who are willing to you know meet you
with help and compassion as well every
time i get to catch up with you even if
it's a little bit
i always feel warm inside and you're
also somebody who i feel like really
resonates with me about music so uh yeah
i appreciate that
i hope you're doing well that was good
thanks man he's david